some more breaking news to bring you now  and there are reports that there has  been a second shooting also in munich  near a metro station marienplatz we  let's bring in our foreign affairs  editor Sam Kiley who joins me now on the  phone and Sam do we know much more about  this reported second shooting no we  don't that is just what it's been as  they've been these reports now some  minutes but the truth of matter is they  are only reports at the State Opening  confirmed by the Munich authorities but  this is precisely the sort of operation  so the terrorist operation but most  major cities in Europe are most afraid  of and have been most planning for that  is a multiple location attack involving  more than one gunman now we don't know  that there is more than one gunman we  don't know that there are multiple  locations but there are these reports  coming in of an attack going on at a  metro station and if